Leon: After the turmoil and the revolution
and the usual dislocation caused by great
revolutions, there has been an implicit social
contract.
"You stay out of politics and we see to it
that your incomes grow, there's stability,
and there's certain semblance of at least
personal security."
So let's start with this contract, between
the people and the regime.
It's under threat.
So let's first discuss what do you think the
reaction of the people will be?
And also, what do you think the regime will
do to survive?
Vladimir: Well, I think two things are certain.
First of all, there was indeed such an implicit
social contract, as you mentioned.
And secondly that it is under severe threat,
and the Kremlin is increasingly struggling
to fulfill its end of that social contract.
The economic situation in our country today
is indeed in free fall.
Leon: Tell us what you see when you travel,
especially in provinces.
I understand the situation is getting to be
quite dire.
Vladimir: Sure.
Well, even if you look at all the major indicators,
even at the surface, we see a double-digit
inflation, we see a massive devaluation of
the national currency, more than 100% since
2014.
Leon: Correct.
Vladimir: We're seeing a decline in the GDP.
We're seeing a decline and a fall in real
incomes to the level of more than a decade
ago.
And sure, this is caused, to a major extent,
by falling oil prices, but here it also has
to be mentioned that during his rule, Putin
has actually increased the dependence of the
Russian economy on oil prices.
Oil and gas accounted for 40% of Russian exports
when Putin came to power.
Today it accounts for 70% of Russian exports.
And also it's the actions of the regime such
as the so-called counter sanctions that you
mentioned also that hit Russian consumers
much harder than they did the intended recipients.
But also the sanctions themselves that have
been caused by flagrant violations of international
law, which was also what the Kremlin regime
did.
Nobody forced them to it.
They chose to do it and these are the consequences.
So we're seeing a major, obviously, deterioration
of the economy.
And also, for example, going back to the oil
prices, today it's about $30 a barrel and
we're seeing 4%-5% decline in GDP.
When Mikhail Kasyanov, for instance, was Prime
Minister, the oil price was about $20-$25
a barrel and we saw 7%-8% growth over the
years.
So it's not, again, we can't blame everything,
or the Kremlin rather, cannot blame everything
on just the oil prices.
It's also the mismanagement.
It's also the destruction of institutions.
It's also the enormous level of corruption,
official corruption that, I think, it's safe
to say is now at the highest level it's ever
been in Russian history.
So it's certain, I think, that the Kremlin
is increasingly struggling to fulfill its
part of the social contract in economic terms.
So in order to maintain its grip on power,
they're increasingly turning to repression
and to a relentless propaganda, finding the
external enemies, rallying up against them,
all these usual things, all these usual tricks
that are not new.
Leon: Right.
Vladimir: And we, as historians, we both saw
many, many examples of this in history.
But we also saw that these tricks and these
attempts to hold onto power usually end the
same way, and I think a very good parallel
would be what happened in our own country
in Russia in the late 1980s, early 1990s when,
as you remember, the political control of
the communist establishment remained in place,
the propaganda machine over the television
remained in place, but it simply became less
and less and less effective as the economic
reality increasingly diverged from the propaganda
image.
This is the proverbial battle between the
television set and the fridge.
And the fridge always wins.
Certainly in Russia, always wins.
And I think however much the current regime
will try to cling to its power, again by finding
enemies, by rallying up its propaganda machine,
by increasing repression and tightening the
screws, as it were, I think the end result
will be the same.
Unfortunately, and this is a very big problem,
and the Kremlin likes to accuse us, members
of the Russian opposition, of being revolutionaries
and preparing for a Russian Maidan.
Of course, I would say that the biggest revolutionaries
of all are the people in the Kremlin itself
today, because they're the ones who destroyed
all the institutions of the state, who turned
the elections into a meaningless farce, who
turned parliament into not a place for discussion,
as they themselves famously said, who turned
all the major media outlets into weapons of
its propaganda machine, and thus destroyed
and eliminated every single legal and constitutional
way of changing the government.
And in doing so, they ensured that whenever
change does come to Russia, political change,
and nothing is forever, and nothing is permanent,
that this change will take the shape of some
kind of a revolutionary process.
As the Kremlin themselves, as Vladimir Putin
himself, will ensure that this will be the
case.
And I'm not saying it with any pleasure because
as a historian, as you said, which I don't
think that revolutions are necessarily a force
for good, especially in our own Russian history,
but this is what the Kremlin's actions are
leading to, that whenever change does come
to our country, and again it will come, nothing
is forever, it will come as some kind of a
revolutionary form.